hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
got a trailer has just dropped and
Lauren has just showed up and I said it
was like here this date it was like five
minutes ago
right before she got here Avengers age
of Ultron trailer number threats I won't
ask you guys a question for her to watch
this video what Marvel Comics do you
think we should read in order to fully
grasp the Avengers like what graphic
novels are there out there that you
think this is the one or these are the
ones anyway watches they allowed I
decide to save the world
to the sky oh I'll take that coming
first in the one path to peace that our
extinction
trick crease reform around the balls
I think something terrible artificial
intelligence
watching people pay for our mistakes
this is why we fight so we can end the
fight well
nice
yo
wait and I will save the world
and right
we all get through this and implants are
nice
speaking about you boys
tear them apart
from the inside
mr. doe
good
when I get chills my nipples get so hard
why you shall see that to the nib I see
it
no like get up close in there I don't
know if they can see it through that
she's it yeah oh you can tell me time
yeah that is how [ __ ] excited I am
for this movie Oh God also how many
movies do we have to make saying that
artificial intelligence is bad not until
artificial intelligence actually takes
over well there's me want to take on the
artificial intelligence it's the
Avengers right
I mean who better than them it's a
simple I mean yeah I was a little bit
kind of disappointed too when I saw that
like oh yeah AI bad of course yeah like
we [ __ ] up and made AI now a heís
taking over from that story has been
done so many times but it's gonna be
happening more please Lauren Lauren why
are the Hulk and the Black Widow thing
since when did that happen
who was gonna believe that that Scarlett
Johansson would go with for Mark Ruffalo
maybe it's in the comics is it is it in
the comics guys I could see Scarlett
Johansson going for Captain America or
Thor well she does go for a cap America
sort of and Winter Soldier she I
would've bet yeah they have that weird
thing yeah me me kiss or she's just a
[ __ ] doesn't matter she's fun I really
think when people are like we need a
[ __ ] they're gonna cast Scarlett
Johansson fair but she's the kind of
[ __ ] that people like she's a hottie but
in that movie um he's just not that into
you know she's a total Hornet yeah oh
that's why they cast her right misled
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver you see a
miniature moment of Quicksilver when he
zooms past and punches Captain America
in the face yeah yeah okay I'm not gonna
lie they're preserving their powers
they're not showing them in the trailer
but Quicksilver is gonna be hard to talk
from Days of Future past right
because he was a [ __ ] scene stealer
he was busy moving he comes in early in
the film and then he leaves kind of
early but he's the one you walked away
thinking about the most yeah like the
weight of the introduces character when
they go to his house mm-hmm it's so
brilliant I'm hoping because I got Aaron
taylor-johnson for this who played like
kick-ass he was in Godzilla and he's a
good actor but more attractive than the
other one but Evan Peters is very
different yaki's he's a different kind
of personality and I like how he's kind
of awkward all the time
fun fact oh um bet you guys didn't even
put this together Aaron taylor-johnson
played kick-ass one a kick-ass his best
friend's was Evan Peters who played
Quicksilver in x-men Days of Future past
Oh interesting huh and that's also a
comic book movie you get facts here I
hope you add in like a little like it
looks like we're gonna get more of
Avengers really working together because
the best part of Avengers 1 was the
finale when they're all like in sync
together and I feel like we're gonna get
more fights at like one shot where they
all are like in a group in there like
fight pose and you're like yeah yeah
that's what we want
yeah and they had that one shot they're
like all jumping tonight oh yeah
literally like this from the side and it
was [ __ ] cool though damn dude that
made us hope the other side is also
jumping and they just like the opening
to the x-men cartoon oh yeah they're
like yeah that would be cool what I did
like about this trailer is you see The
Avengers bonding and because in the
first one there was a lot of like banter
and a lot of we're not getting a long
kind of thing and this one I feel like
we're gonna get more of the heart of all
these characters coming together and you
do get teases of their sense of humor
every now and again because that's one
thing I really wanted
be kept as the sense of humor of all
these characters like I'm not doing
anything tomorrow night they surprised
me today yeah he surprisingly didn't
feature Thor a lot in this trailer he
was in it fully they did show him with
his shirt off in the trailer what's bad
sleigh that's the money shot right but
why didn't they show yourself Chris
thank you Chris Evans got a shirt on I
don't know it would have been cool the
scene without a shirt on right he's got
a good body yeah so story they should
have a bouncing pecs competition I
wonder if they can do that is that hard
no I can do it Bam Bam Bam Bam how do
you do that chest muscles baby that's
how it works you can help me I think
happy yeah this trailer just filled with
cool action shots when Scarlett
Johansson's stretch by swoops up the
shoot
G we both figured out oh [ __ ] I don't
want to play that game
tokyo miko they always show little bits
and pieces of Hulk Buster versus Hulk I
want them to stop showing shots of that
because that might be the coolest fight
out of the whole film and I don't want
to see any more footage of it because
I'm a bit given away when you're like I
saw the whole movie in the trailer yeah
he wasn't I don't like it when they give
away too many action scenes we don't
need a period I don't think that's gonna
be the case I think this whole movies
gonna be filled with ash sure but I
don't want to give away the best shots
my favorite shot in the first Avengers
was when it's one shot and it's going
around to all the Avengers and like I'm
so glad I didn't show that in the
trailer and I'm hoping we get cool shops
I feel like Marvel does a really good
job with that I feel like they do a
really good job making a variety of
climactic action scenes mm-hmm you know
that really get you excited in the
trailer and then surprising the movie
yeah I would say the same thing but
that's how I affect women
yeah how's your girlfriend mmm I don't
know she's had some dudes house that
sucks for you yeah she's always at this
dude's house what dude
Tyrone Magnus is that a porn star ah no
no my girlfriend's not talking to Tyrone
Magnus Tyrone stay away from her you may
be buffer than me but I'm willing to ask
[ __ ] you if that's what it takes
oh that's right establishing dominance I
don't know who we're seeing at the very
last shot of the trailer I'm not gonna
lie I'm not one of them comic book savvy
people about that yeah I don't know who
that is but it looks intimidating it's
probably one of the bad guys anyway guys
thanks for mentioning this video was out
10 minutes ago if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects where it's so film related and
you could check out Lauren Goss channel
where some films so vlogging and films
and what else does your channel have
advice life advice cuz Lauren has a
degree in life yeah you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter because we have
social networks and it allows us to stay
more connected with you guys and you get
to like see what we do all day long
yeah pictures it's like wow tweet
they're more than just youtubers I
really know them Sanjay rec ha I love a
little I every time you come on than
someone's complimenting another girl I
love Alyssa be crazy and the real
rejects you guys are hilarious I love
fried chicken and Alyssa is really hot
give me a shout-out please peace Sanjay
oh boy oh boy I'm looking at your
profile picture right now already not a
fan he's into Avenger okay listen I'm
really Lauren's good at communications
she knows people and well and I know
people well so based off this photo
we're gonna describe who we think you
are internally Sanjay you look like a
man who smokes a lot of weed out of
honestly depression you look really
depressed and I
it's really confused confused yeah are
you a confused person in life like what
is it are you worried that you might be
gay I mean I get it I get a
contemplation gay vibe from this guy
can you reenact the face and he's making
yeah that's pretty good you need to like
do your hair oh no one touches the RAI
guys hair
not even me